وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بليكن قد رحب بالهدنه الخامسه بين طرفي
الصراع في السودان
وحذف بلنكن في تغريده على تويتر طرفاي
الصراع على الالتزام بانهاء القتال وضمان
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق عاقلت
الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان نابلينكن
تعاهد خلال لقاء مع الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريج بالضغط من اجل
وقف دائم للقتال في السودان وحمايه
المدنيين وضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
نعمل معا بشكل وثيق لمعالجه الازمه في
السودان ونامل التوصل الى وقف اطلاق نار
اكثر ديمومه ووضع حد للاعمال العدائيه
والمساعده في اعاده السودان للمسار الذي
كان عليه والى حكومه يقودها المدنيون
بينما نتعامل مع وضع انسانيين يزداد صعوبه
هناك
ومن جانبه قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
انه يحاول الى جانب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي التوسط للتواصل لوقف اطلاق النار
في السودان
اعبر عن امتنان وتقديري للتعاون بشان
السودان احاول الى جانب الوزير بلنكن
التوسط للتوصل الى وقف اطلاق نار ناجح قد
حققنا بعض النجاح لكن ليس في المستوى الذي
نرغب في الوصول اليه ممتنون للدعم
الامريكي في عمليه نقل موظفينا والتي
استفاد منها 1200 موظف من الامم المتحده
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه والبعثات المختلفه
من الخرطوم الى برج سودان في خضم وضع صعب
للغايه